l'enquêté sur les chiffres ils sont
exacts nabila 400000 euros par mois le
couple nabila est thomas 650000 euros
par mois et ça c'est uniquement les
placements de produits qu'elle est aussi
une marque de beauté à la sonde il avec
amazon en plus et pour info les
influenceurs en tout cas de télé réalité
issue date-là et ont la réputation d'
accepter tout et n'importe quoi pour
faire de l'argent il refuse plein de
contrastes art qui choisissent les
marques par me anne marque de sextoys
qui les a contactés récemment ils ont
refusé donc ils prennent pas tous les
contrats ils sont hyper sélectifs et
avec ça ils réussissent à gagner
beaucoup d'argent donc franchement bravo
guillaume et tu dis une bêtise parce que
je crois que thomas ne fait plus de
placement de produit interdit de poster
sur instagram yal'ancien 10 l'ont fait
sur les réseaux sociaux il faut croire
qu'ils sont déportés vol sur tik tok ça
ouais tik tok snapshot ils ont aussi son
style sont surtout les réseaux ils sont
très puissants franchement ça c'est un
modèle de réussite un nouveau modèle
mais franchement je sais qu'on compte
les bouses guillaume n'a donc c'est la
fin du marché qu'on compte les bouses la
réussite ça je ne sais pas sur cinq six
ans à ce juge soit 7,6 à 4000 euros par
mois qu'elle s'embarque alors la touche
et 2011 pour un truc d'amazon alors
amazonie avec vous et vos tables et
thaïlandais il ya un million
d'exclusivité en plus ça fait 2 millions
comme 1,2 million dont 2,2 millions
d'euros c'est des choses qui lui donne
elle
fait toujours marrer quand on débat
gagnent de l'argent et on donne de
l'argent tant mieux pour elle après
c'est une belle réussite parce qu'au
départ on habille la voix la butte en
france et seul truc ce serait pourrait
payer des impôts en france a lancé
l'idée à l'antenne des enfants ça se
fait cambrioler excusez moi non médias
les bleus risquent habitants frontale et
paris soit blu-ray talent et lagardère
tu en as d'accord mais
je suis c'est un jeu à 400000 euros à la
commune en voyant un truc sécurisé c'est
quand même pas le rebelle de démocratie
non plus on part quand même particulier
pas de s'installer là bas là c'est vrai
que on va dire que c'est voilà on peut
on peut critiquer
attend d elle elle gagne pas elle elle
fait pas le sait pas son argent en
france en faisant des concerts à bercy
ou ou son territoire a fait des postes
les potes c'est mondiale guillaume on
est d'accord elle pose sur le monde
entier mais qui la
suivront elles elle pose pas pour des
marques
française
habite à dubaï pour l'instant elle en
train de déjouer un système fiscal ou
fiscaux geoffrey fiscale là d'accord
fiscal des fiscaux voilà si elle veut
déjouer ça d'accord pour moi comment ça
me dérange pas qu'ils restent à dubaï le
truc c'est qu'il ne sera pas dubaï elle
va revenir en france et même elle passe
du temps en france c'est ça que je
rejoins steevy c'est dérangeant parce
que elle va se servir du système
français quand ce sera l'éducation quand
ce sera la santé elle a la dimension
mais canal à dubaï la moi même dans des
raids ou ballon mais elle est très bien
à dubaï alors pourra justement on ne
combat on suppute combien je gagne parce
que m c'est assez opaque et on vous
explique dans le dock pourquoi notamment
fiscalement il ya quelques quelques
virages je crois qu'après six nabila
benatia a choisi de domicilier sa
société dans ce tout petit état
américain à plus de onze mille
kilomètres de dubaï ce n'est pas par
amour des voyages en avion il y a une
vraie bonne raison
c'est un paradis fiscal il ya une petite
spécificité en plus de payer quasiment
pas d'impôt c'est qu'il ya aucune
transparence il ya aucune obligation de
transparence non ce que gagne la villa
grâce à sa marque de cosmétiques déjà
bon c'est que ça ne rapportera rien à
l'état français puisque ce ne sera pas
imposée en france même si elles se sont
dit à dubaï mais il n'y a aucune
transparence on peut pas savoir ce
qu'ils gagnent probablement pas mal
d'argent
estimée parce que je peux vous dire
sérieusement elle a refusé deux
propositions au cinéma ah oui quand-même
mouais écoutez donc voir du quartier par
personne à critiques moi je vous dis les
gens qui réussissent tant mieux pour eux
mais voilà chacun fait sa vie et elle
mène sa barque